foreign
you cannot be serious goblins working
with Rookwood
makes no sense
it is rather unorthodox to say the least
unorthodox it's inconceivable it's
ah fig welcome to the stream folks I'll
see what I can find out hi there Star
Wars documented are you there sir I was
able to search the Restricted Section
while you were with Professor Inferno
just a kid
what hey Everest
wait
hey gorgeous Granger Restricted Section
but how hey Lewis hey ale thinking on it
perhaps it's best you spare me the
details fair enough realize in fact the
book was below the Restricted Section as
it appeared on them hey Adrian I want to
hear everything first let's have a look
oh dear hey Reuben all these Pages seem
to be this is a PS5
it appears someone has got to the book
before us
yeah this is uh I'm Slytherin hey Ashley
time to study what remains
perhaps something useful that may take
some time I've been uh streaming fairly
intermittently what's here hello
Hogwarts
I found the book another
Hey Taylor godric's heart the man we saw
before parts of a Rackham was a
professor here the first memory showed
him and three other professors using
ancient magic to restore a hamlet how's
everyone doing Miriam was right and the
second memory they were talking to a
student who started as a fifth year like
I did
she could see traces of magic too why
those memories hey b-boy
look we'll explain now I'll have to take
it with me to London the Headmaster has
insisted that I speak directly to the
minister about George's death
I understand
I'll see what I can learn about the
missing pages while you're gone good who
here is uh
I know a lot of people have work is
improving by the day but you'll want to
pay attention in her bottle I love the
game potions there's more to Magic I'm
not good at it I don't need to keep me
occupied while you're gone and I'm
taking my time to finish it too because
I don't want to just rush through
accomplished when I return
oh and don't neglect your friends you
may be surprised by how much you can
learn from them as well
so I learned recently that you can't go
back and complete side quests if you
level out of them so I need to go do
some side quests
see if we've a new school Champion meet
me at the usual place for the final
round of crossed ones also the training
dummy is still available
meet me in lower hogsfield as soon as
possible
foreign
yeah I was just kind of rushing through
and doing the main quests but I don't
want to I don't want to miss things
so much going on
good morning good evening
hello Jeb vlogs
hi Christine
foreign
depends I don't know
first one for the Nostalgia or possibly
Order of the Phoenix
what's uh what's your favorite
hello Sheldon
hey floor mat
what's everyone's favorite Harry Potter
film
no just uh just on YouTube I'm streaming
but I will I don't have a twitch but
I'll make one
what's everyone's favorite book as well
I hope so Ellie
if you guys enjoy the streams please
give it a like
I guess my next question is why is that
your choice for favorite movie
foreign
I'd like to practice with the training
dummy excellent idea this time will be a
bit more of a challenge ready
brilliant wonderful I'll set things up
so much happens in order of the Phoenix
it feels like multiple times again if
you need to stop practicing before you
finish all of them let me know
and send you
something
good one
[Music]
whoops
got two Trigger Happy
thanks Christian
are you average cricketer
[Music]
thanks
thanks Connor
um I don't watch a lot of uh streamers
to be honest with you
I watch uh nerd Theory with uh Star Wars
Theory who helps me with this Channel
and and Josh
mainly just watch pre-recorded stuff
hey Sean
I'm in southern
thanks uh LOL Mysterio
our Dev
it was only a training dummy true but
it's
saying dummies will think twice before
challenging you again
formidable and crossed ones other Jews
had better okay time for uh cross ones
part three
hello Lucan is the final round of cross
ones ready big match today
it all comes
see how this goes
with it all ready for a shot at glory
how am I gonna do guys
dripped out
certainly am really
brilliant yes Sebastian AJ let's get
who likes Michael we can make this a
real victory
that's the spirit so
everybody
let's go
you left me
nothing
thanks for the Super Chat Connor
[Music]
I have a
um
12 inch Phoenix Feather core with uh
made of U
um slightly slightly bendy
make sure
that was nothing that was nothing
strong now to the victor goes
and so
attention you get given a wand and then
you can modify
you can also import your ones from
wizardingworld.com
thank you it's been an honor you
were I suppose I should get back to my
school
I wonder how my
herbs are doing I haven't tended them in
ages
favorite spell safari is incendio
because I can just run around and set
stuff on fire but
I'm sure I'll learn some other cool
stuff
sorry what did I win for that he said I
won something
see anything
did I win something
kind of like these ones
yeah I like Doctor Who
I haven't watched it in a long time I
used to watch it with
um David Tennant
hey Atlas
foreign
yeah the the advanced potion making book
was for the new level potions class
I'm gonna do a video on all the spells
in this game at some point
yeah I like this robe the most I think
I has a conflict
good night Helly thanks for watching
oh level seven
my level's too high for these now
how do you collect manually collect
challenge rules I don't even know this
foreign
robe appearances
oh
didn't know this
huh
good to know
the Death Eater mask is a bit morbid
I'm gonna go with these the mcgonagalls
trying to make him look as
unthreatening as possible
oh the cloak
oh interesting
I kind of don't like that you can change
the appearance so easily I wish you had
to find items that look a certain way
it's almost too easy
did everyone choose the same house that
they were sorted into on Wizarding World
oh I've got to do this
well not yet
I'm gonna do the uh the low level stuff
because I don't want to out level them
yeah
revelio
haven't learned how to efficiently
navigate the castle yet
still just running everywhere
but it's a good way to find my way
around I guess
yeah I've got to do uh
hello I don't believe we've met oh hello
Nora
pardon me if I seem a little distracted
at the moment everyone thinks I'm
utterly balmy
Samantha thinks I'm potty but it's this
pain this painting I never noticed which
text is uh distracted
or the other text something
[Music]
more if I have the time I may look could
be intriguing
I've been racking my brains long enough
I hope you'll have better luck than I
have I think my Patronus was a Jack
Russell Terrier or something do come and
find me if you stumble on something
Illuminating
I'm gonna just gonna do Side Quests for
a while I don't want to continue the
story until
I've got these out of the way
handy resource indeed revelia
okay good to know
yeah still getting used to the streaming
stuff
good morning Professor garlic how
wonderful it is to see you again Lenora
dear oh here this is my fourth fifth
stream in uh four years
you can find out your Patronus on the
Patronus quiz on wizardingworld.com
[Music]
look at those glasses
thank you how thrilling it is to have
everyone back together again
this year will be filled with
enchantments and excitement but the most
important thing cultivated in her
biology is knowledge
The Prudent herbologist is no more
afraid of the venomous tentacular than
the bouncing bone
now then today we will be acquainting
ourselves with the mellifluous of the
Mandrake group
Akio
pick our fibrous friends a bit more
comfortable shall we
cover your ears everyone let's protect
Arya
now everyone grip their Mandrake by the
tendrils and give it a firm tug
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
like a warm dirty blanket put a mandrake
right at ease
thank you thank you I'm very sorry about
that yeah Centaur like uh friends he
could be yeah he's a good divination
professor
good work everyone
now we're on next time we'll be planting
dittany at our potting tables
yes Professor firstly well done with
your Mandrake they can be rather
difficult to get a grasp of
I'll say Lily I look ridiculous yes I've
I've
so remember to keep those ears protect
this find you some seeds I already have
some Professor pick them up in hogsmead
you fit the magic neap
your own potting table here in the
classroom wasn't easy to spare one on
what's everyone's favorite class plant
the seats down
general not just in the game even
[Music]
to a bit of magic they will take time to
grow
let's see how to balance my staff this
arrangement
s
radiant in the wiggenweld potion as you
all should know from Professor Sharp's
class
hold on a sec guys
foreign
thank you
[Music]
once you can be harvested your
auditioning will be ready you guys can
hear me we can weld potion
say we Branch out introduce you to a
different sort of Flora the Chinese
chomping cabbage
we'll find the sun okay it's a better
suited to use his outside of a cauldron
the cabbages do get testy without
something to chew 4 fortunately I have a
dummy for them to gnaw on be a deer and
let them have a good jumping yes
Professor they're in the other
Greenhouse it's just at the end of the
Footbridge leading out of this room your
classmate Mr Pruitt has kindly offered
to accompany you come back and see me
when you're finished oh and mind your
fingers take bite
hello
saw you on your way to hogsmeade the
other day
nice to meet you nice work in defense
against the dark arts by the way excuse
me
your jewel is Sebastian and he's good
things he's really good but you outright
slaughtered him it was brilliant oh
well
thank you I nearly put Sebastian in his
place myself I mean I would have here we
are home of the Chinese Chomp go on now
see that dummy just toss the cabbages at
it they'll do the rest
what's up
yeah Harry has a plot armor for sure
um
thanks key Dottie uh my favorite movie
is probably older of the Phoenix or
possibly Philosopher's Stone because of
the Nostalgia Factor
sorry how do I do this
in town
hold L1
okay
okay look at that
I'm not used to playing on PlayStation
I got a PlayStation for this game after
honking daffodils in tatters
vicious little bastards aren't they my
kind of plants not like stupid boopa
tubers and bouncing bulbs the kind of
plants yeah um
but well imagine that wasn't a dummy
trust me Leander I was imagining it the
entire time you were I mean of course
you're uh not someone to be trifled with
I see that dog weed and death cap has
more of them fun fact Molly Weasley
Pruitt family married
you get the idea anyway we uh probably
ought to head back to class
take your time I'll see you back in
class
revelio
yeah PS5 had an update just now
I logged in about an hour ago
so I don't know when they launched it
oh my control is low
[Music]
the best time to plant a seed is last
season the second best time is now
I should think Professor garlic would be
more careful with her man drinks I
attended to the Chinese chomping
cabbages Professor remarkable plants
they need to fix the voice
don't see any bite marks or
digits I'm good I haven't checked what's
new in the update yet let me see oh
Jaime you get to see your skill in the
soil continue to Blossom
did the update say
PS5
Legacy update
fixed an issue with mail not properly
triggering sequential mission
fixed a rare crash when respawning NPCs
in the world
fixed crash with some NPC schedules
um
corrected VFX presentation of Rogue
transformation fixed a stability issue
when skipping cut scenes so that that
kind of thing
magical plants have so much to offer I'm
eager to learn more I'm
will tend to you a book was good
I suppose
hey
okay next Quest
I'll have to check my dignity
I'm hearing
to make anything grow we must first
understand it that goes for plants as
well as friendships kindness and concern
are as necessary in the greenhouse as in
the Great Hall
yeah I'm sure I'm sure they'll release
quidditch at some point they must
should I wait for this didn't he for
three minutes
or should I head off
ah
revelio
oh what do we have here
brown leather gloves
yeah if if it is actually 1890 then
Dumbledore's nine but
I think they they redacted that so just
to kind of leave it a little more
ambiguous
I'm gonna wait for this debt knee
[Music]
so they're in with the early takeaway oh
not a lot of Gryffindor interestingly
[Music]
I'll leave soon
also guys please give the stream a like
if you enjoy it and do more
Alpha buff trailing
MK Tommy tricks
yeah someone is developing a multiplayer
mod but it will cap at eight people
and it's probably going to take a while
um
before it's kind of actually ready to
play I think it's supposed to be really
buggy
uh wolf Spain cures
um lycanthropy
for werewolves
didn't he
heals wounds like if you get splenged
like uh Hermione uses it on Ron after
they operate from the ministry
because he got flinched
we have here
I've done a video on Merlin if you want
to learn more about him
did that one a couple of years ago
no not all slytherins are bad I've done
a video on five slytherins that are good
in fact
well I think it's called five Southerns
that aren't evil
thanks odivius
I appreciate it
potions
time for potions
okay
hi Capitan pone
foreign
T family history so that'll be out maybe
in a week or two I think
and that includes ominous
right now I'm discussing the game as if
it's Canon
uh I'll probably flip-flop a bit on that
depending on how the game unravels but I
like to think of it as Canon right now
because it hasn't obviously contradicted
anything as far as I can tell Professor
black would never allow that it
is
I bet he knows
thanks vipin wiping vipin
potions is one of the most challenging
and hazardous subjects taught at this
school as fifth years you will be
required to reach new heights of both
discipline and intellect
you will begin this term by brewing a
Wigan weld potion
Mr takar can you tell us why this
particular potion might come in handy
yes Professor sharp the Wigan welcome
this is my uh first playthrough it's my
second character
but uh oh sorry second playthrough but I
haven't beaten the game
point for Ravenclaw
for today's class is completed each of
you will have brewed a Wigan World
potion of your own
I feel like they were quite careful with
regards to considering Canada
it's definitely more Canon than cursed
child
use a strong even motion when crushing
your ingredients
please be meticulous when adding powder
to your potions one errant sneeze could
be disastrous
what's your favorite type of video on
the channel because I need to know what
you guys want
do you like the history of videos
I see most of you have not forgotten how
to stir
not an easy potion to brew
well done and from what I hear of your
recent exploits thanks for joining Dylan
you'd also do well
tomorrow's potion Professor Weasley had
you acquire the recipe from Jay Pippins
correct yes sir good for the moment you
can find the ingredients you need in my
office but in the future you'll be
expected to provide your own ingredients
some can be harvested from the prawns
you grow in your herbology class and
rarer ones can be purchased others
however may be harder to obtain and will
require you to be a bit more
resourceful come and see me when you
finished Brewing
and we'll see if it was skill or luck
the first time around
considered keeping this year after the
rumors
did I hear Professor sharp say that your
permission to go into his office
yes but why does that matter to you
brilliant
brilliant and it matters because you can
be a part of something true Gareth
Weasley I'm Gareth by the way Gareth
Weasley bit of a prodigy with potions if
I do so so myself pleasure to me
interesting
wait are you related to Professor
Weasley she's my aunt keeps too close an
eye on me for comfort I've gonna make a
Weasley family tree video as well to
account for all these new anyways
control size brain can Brew in a Juris
potion I'm working on something that's
certain to be spectacular
I was missing one tiny last ingredient
that will add that extra spark I suspect
that's where I come in you're as clever
as I'd hoped
simply need a single fupa feather as
you'll already be in Sharp's office with
his permission
grab it for me
I'll get you the foyer feather as long
as your certain shop won't miss it I
assure you he won't feathers aren't that
valuable wait until you see what I'm
brewing hurry back to me when you have
the feather
okay
thank you
what else has he got in here
no no no don't spoil the game for anyone
revelio why would you do that
[Music]
ocean stations organized and free of
clutter here's the Flopper feather you
wanted brilliant thank you this is going
to take a moment to prove you should get
back to Brewing you're a Juris you guys
enjoy the stream please
if you run out of ingredients oh well
Professor sharp must have learned a lot
during his time as a world
he talked about it more
Juris potion
not so sure about these time limits
the game's gonna take me long enough I
don't know if I need to wait on top of
that
and now we add the mallow suite and
that's odd what's happening hi we can
wear potions utter wait it's not
supposed to
uh the reboot rumors I haven't discussed
them publicly but
um they've already been dispelled
his new cursed Child movie coming out
is impressed that you were able to
answer Professor Sharp's question about
the Wicked World potion oh
oh student I've heard much about you
um thank you I'm I mean by the way I
think we'll go to get a quidditch never
seen anyone maybe some Flawless
resemblance of an official multiplayer
DLC perhaps
maybe like Guild wars-esque
I'm glad I was able to get it right the
first time you must simply
some students seem so confounded by
poison I sneaky reflex it's as if
they're written in gobbledygook
fascinating Language by the way neither
here
I didn't get very far
how much further than this gateway to
the far Stars before my next class
speaking of stars we'll be in astronomy
together you'll love it I went away the
week that the game came out no doubt I'm
trying to balance it with making videos
so I haven't played as much as I may
have wanted to
and every time I play I'm writing down
video ideas and taking notes so it's
very slow going
I Thunder God
yeah math expansion would be excellent
they can always make you know DLC with
the other schools
brood and adora's potion as you asked
Professor I'm surprised you had the time
with lots of Wizarding schools helping
Mr Weasley Brew chaos
I'm not sure what you're talking about
Professor you will not earn favor what
was your suggestion Jeb responsibility
for your actions I missed it just you
heed my warning as for the work you did
today at your own cauldron I will say
you've done well I confess I was
skeptical given the advanced nature of
this class and the fact you're a new
student I'm glad I was able to meet you
I'm a uh Slytherin
and you do well to remember that you're
not a potions Master quite yet I think
they might do the other schools just
give it some time might take a while you
should gain an understanding of the
ingredients themselves not in Rush pay
particular attention in herbology the
plants you nurture there are often
essential to the potions you brew here
now I recommend that you find a safe
location in which to practice Brewing
you cannot leave a hot cauldron simply
anywhere but are we all
dismissed
level eight
that was an interesting class thanks to
you it wasn't precisely what I had in
mind but it was still brilliant I
appreciate your help I hope sharp wasn't
too disagreeable when you handed in your
potion heard him talking about taking
responsibility
Professor sharp wasn't happy
leave me out of your grand plans next
time sorry hello hello hopefully he's
already forgotten about it
shop may seem Gruff but hard but a few
galleons he blew up a potion or two in
his day
spielf next time we talk I promise I
think other schools would be the biggest
piece of DLC they could add they could
do
you know Durham strain then ilvermorny
it's called
uh okay what do I want to do next
what have I got I got some new stuff
yeah chamber yeah
can see that happening
how do I get the Lucius Malfoy one
tendle that's what I want
I'm so bad at navigating the menu still
and
all of the different places I have to go
is
I definitely haven't adjusted to it yet
I'll do this one next
I meant to do this a while ago oh how do
I
collections try wizard tournament would
be great
foreign
thanks George much appreciated
hey true science
hey pumpkin pumpkin
where do I go for this one
yeah that's a good idea Jeff yep
definitely I like that I have a daughter
I haven't thought of that one
thanks Dylan
Grindelwald and Tom Riddle I think a
young I think Grindelwald would best
a young Tom Riddle I don't think he
would he would intact I don't think Tom
would antagonize him
thanks Nick
appreciate that
we have the Channel's been popping off
since the game came out which is great
can't complain
hi Leila
okay
locate on the map
you can't imagine how inconvenient
Rebellion
so what do I have to do I have to
stairwell going up
that's it
foreign
shouldn't I be able to
open this if I'm invisible
[Music]
uh
uh okay
that makes sense
I didn't know that
oh okay
I'll try again
weird
okay I'll try that one again in a bit
um
but for the time being
let's put this back
should I try again
oh was it open oh I didn't see that
oh
very nice
thanks B
yeah this is before Grindelwald I think
I can't remember what year he's born I
think he's born just after Dumbledore so
he's born I think he would be a lot he
would be alive now just about I think he
was maybe
because Dumbledore was 1881.
foreign
I've done a video on the five
differences between Voldemort and
Grindelwald and I've also done a video
on who is more powerful so
keep an eye out for those
am I going to the right place for this
one though
[Music]
thanks Pippin
wiping Rebellion
oh
Crimson lock scarf
oh this looks like what he wanted
yeah they said 1890 and then they
redacted it so I'm not entirely sure
what the year is supposed to be
okay
what is happening
that's a good idea yeah maybe I'll work
on something like that
does anyone know where I have to go for
this find the third Landmark from
Arthur's treasure map
do I need to look at this map
is this is this an item that I have or
is this a map
is this a painting that I need to find
it looks like a painting
who knows where this is
because I don't know
yeah I think it'll be
single player for a long time
revelio
laughs
it's on the staircase
Rebellion
it's like a landscape
one isn't it
revelio
Ah that's it that's it that's it that's
it that's it
which one is it
one of these
lumos
portrait of the snowy this is it
okay what do I do with it
revelio
I don't know what's going on
foreign
what's happening
okay
ah yeah
that's that's it
that makes sense okay okay
there was a doorway hidden within the
pool this looks like the portrait from
the map
I wonder what came about to search
historians uniform good
Rebellion
lumos
was that through the other side
okay
let's do this
my my
if you guys enjoy the stream please give
it a like
thank you thank you
revelio
you can collect the rewards at any time
for a completed challenge though right
everything all right yes I'm sorry I'm
just I'm Nelly by the way I'm just so
excited that the daily and keys are back
the walk Keys the dedalian keys surely
you've seen them flying about rumor is
that a former headmistress Professor mon
conjured them to protect the contents of
certain locked cabinets years ago
Professor black couldn't be bothered to
disenchant the Keys and they appear
every few years you should try to catch
one
why would I do that each key will lead
you to a locked cabinet somewhere in the
castle if you manage to get the key into
the cabinet lock not an easy task you
may find a reward
perhaps I'll give it a go I hope I hope
you do
in fact
he had one of the trees in the astronomy
Tower
okay I follow a few keys at least if you
manage to open a cabinet I'll uh I'll
finish
this one
first
oh does it take a long time weeks okay
well
maybe I'll do part one
at some point
gonna do it for the drip
what is this okay
right don't
don't everyone hates you
why because Hogwarts is full of bullies
and spoil Sports Leander Pruitt's one of
the worst that no Talent Moon mind oh
don't forget to make some new friends
and so I bought my collection room my
gobstone collection that is
hoping someone would want to play I am
earlier with gobstones little balls like
marble
I haven't much interest in a game that
sprays you with odors only if you lose
which I never do or at least not often
people can be so cruel just because
they're sprayed all over with smelly
gobstones spit it's their own fault for
losing
Imelda is one of the worst losers ever
written a story and now those poor
Losers of take
sounds as if you caused the smelly
situation and they responded accordingly
I didn't make the
side quests
I don't think I know the necessary it's
gonna enjoy them I hate someone
talented
I'll see what I can do I'd appreciate
the help if you do find all of my
gobstones do come and see me again I'll
be back to playing snake pit and Jack
Stone by myself in no time
okay not doing that one I don't like
that it
by default directs you to the next Quest
shouldn't do that
yeah we've
we've waited for this game for so long
I'm not in a hurry to just
rush through it
no fun in that
revelio
often another adventure are we
lumos
I wouldn't do that one yet
incendio
Rebellion
now you're just coming from here
so much better find anything yet
hello Arthur thought you might like to
know that my map led to a doorway hidden
within a portrait oh how clever mine led
to The Boathouse barely found the
treasure before I saw the Headmaster
coming he shoot me out of there but
there are lots of things
what did you find I found what I believe
is an authentic historian I've done a
video oh that's the most horrifying
curse I think it's top ten most awful
curses or something like that
transmography and torture is the worst
curse
but remember the name transmography and
torture
thanks for watching David
I can't remember where I first
I found that out Jeb
I'm gonna do this one next we'll start
it
I think in the top 10 list all of the
unforgivables were there but
uh they weren't near the top
far as I recall
Rebellion
oh
I haven't been in here yet
revelio the question is what do I need
this will be more useful when I have
something to identify
nothing in here
all right good
oh Deke
hello
I can't speak with him yet
must be too soon
thank you
and Sunday
[Music]
I think that Voldemort was more powerful
but Grindelwald was more intelligent so
really depends
it also depends on the timeline
what year they do all
right stuff to say
handy resource indeed your Field Guide I
think crucio is the worst of the
unforgivables in my opinion
Harry described it as like having his
what is it bones set on fire while his
skull
I wonder where it might lead me
do I follow this thing
it's in here isn't it
oh it's in the cabinet there's the
cabinet how do I get this key in there
brilliant nice
I have an old coin perhaps Nelly knows
what it means
I've always said that travel broadens
the mind it's true yeah Imperial could
be could be worse long term Rebellion
but
thanks for tuning in Bosch eye surgery
I don't think Harry was very special
compared to
many many other Wizards to be honest
with you
Rebellion
lumos
thank you
Rebellion
foreign
I'd better keep an eye on high places
around the school for zenobia's
gobstones
hello Nelly I managed to get the um
a curious token I looked into it earlier
today some sort of house but it is being
posted everywhere unlocks house chests I
call them house chairs this seems to
happen every couple of months
you film
see this through and find the Slytherin
house chest
Italians and a historian's uniform
crazy Dara
I think I got my first book in 197.
this must seems only to find more house
tokens if I'm to open this I'd like to
see a TV show on the Marauders
the origins of Hogwarts and the founders
uh young Snape would be good I'd really
like to see young Snape and also Tom
Riddle I think that might be the most
interesting for me actually
how inconvenient travel was before
my character's called jar jar gaunt
he's a beveral yeah
yeah those cut scenes of young Tom were
great
oh
thanks Horatio
if you guys enjoy the stream please give
it a like
which Wizarding family is my favorite
um
tough question lumos
spot must be a clue
I should look around in case it's nearby
let's get you back to your frame little
moth
how do I return them off
Nora that I solved the puzzle of that
empty frame
yeah the black family maybe most
interesting
um
the gaunts very interesting
Lenora I solved the mystery of that
painting
I'm afraid I can't tell you Lenora
huge hi Poplar Ponderosa
is it out on your own
yeah one who told you about it in the
first place
imagine solving a riddle that I
mentioned and they're not telling me
practically
I haven't interacted with ominous much
yet to be honest with you
oh
neckwear
oh my goodness I wasn't wearing anything
on my neck
oh cool
we go here cracking
you see he's a more infuriating
know-it-tool
I'm good with this
okay what do I do now
what should I do next guys
comment
good night jester
hi kids okay let's do hackets
isn't that a main quest
uh
uh where do I go for this
off on another adventure are we
thank you
where is uh heckett's classroom
astronomy town
dark arts Tower handy resource in
sources
which is where here
I can't remember
let's go here
thank you
no I won't
lied I'm most pleased to be included
oops
okay
I tracked it
so this should be it right
this isn't the quest
yeah yeah yeah yeah this is it this is
it this is it
is it okay well I don't want to go to
the flu Flame
God of a mess
foreign
oh is that what it is
how do I uncheck this
I don't want this
anymore
oh is it oh I see
you can't imagine how inconvenient
travel was before I invented
yeah I think you need to get out of
Hogwarts for a bit I've been here for a
while
revelio
I've done three dueling quests
Rebellion lumos
I've always said that travel broadens
the mind
revelio
look like you've seen a ghost
if only
though from the Restricted Section no
you are
it's possible Jeb
I actually discussed that a few videos
ago
I don't want to leave right now do I
have to do I have to leave to do part of
this Quest
I don't think so
lumos
I'm just gonna do this uh packets Quest
very nice
and just look around a bit
Maybe
handy resource indeed York Field Guide I
mostly
oh my goodness
foreign
it's tracked
where do I do the 10 dodges
oh I have to leave Hogwarts to do this
are we
okay I'll go to the Forbidden Forest
foreign
Forest
incendia
Rebellion
lumos
what is this thing oh
potatoes
uh-oh Rebellion
uh oh
yeah yeah I know
I just missed click a lot on this
controller
what about um
assistant
foreign
[Music]
thank you
you'll have to fight eventually
not good at dodging
with your skills
foreign
oh this is getting bad
where are they all
love yourself
foreign
yeah yeah I forgot about Ikea
Rebellion
lumos
okay okay okay okay
what have we got here
thank you
if you ask me
oh I didn't know that
so that's good to know
I won't take it as an insult
S
no no no no
him
was I supposed to go in there
oh
do I go in this this could prove
dangerous if I'm not careful
well well okay what should I get rid of
foreign
which gear do I have to throw out
oh
I'll equip this
I see
getting the hang of it guys
it's taking a while
foreign
yeah maybe I'll do that oh well I'll try
and find some more enemies first I guess
do some more dodging
there
huh
yeah I'll go to hoax made so I can sell
this stuff
foreign
thanks for tuning in
we lived here I wonder nobody will miss
one me feeling
looking for trouble incendio
yeah
huh
almost done
revelio
I need to stop
I'm doing this
oh Wigan weld potion
um favorite spells so far is incendio
there's no telling what lies and wait
for me in there
good to know thank you
seconds
yes
okay let's go back
I guess I can use the flu
Network
you know what I'm gonna go to hogsmeade
First
and sell this stuff
thank you
come on
oh
um yes I will be using the unforgivable
curses
okay let's make sure I have the right
gear equipped
we'll go from there
yeah I'm gonna sell the rest
I'm looking about plenty of wonderful
books to stoke a curious mind like yours
a pleasure doing business with you
let me know if there's anything else I
could
thanks for tuning in true sighted
is this the best one
yes it is
yeah I know you guys let's look at what
we have shall we
let me know if there's anything else I
can do to help is it worth uh going to
the shop and seeing what things I can
buy right now or no
foreign
uh yeah yeah I'll just get closer to the
mic I've been kind of far away is that
is that better
I've been mumbling
good good
my bad
foreign
[Music]
spell and then probably sign off after
that for the night
I hope you were able to take care of
Essa I completed all of your most recent
assignments
well done then you're ready to learn
Expelliarmus pay close attention
the disarming charm May often be all you
need to defeat the most powerful dark
witches and wizards you might encounter
spellcasting requires a focus mind
and a steady wound
good work Professor do you have a moment
I do what is it
actually perhaps another time hmm
perhaps good to see you think things
through
use this new spell
um
but keep practicing experience
okay guys I think I'm done for the night
thank you to everyone who who tuned in
um I'll probably be back
uh tomorrow or the night after that
and there's going to be a video dropping
tomorrow as well
you bet I hope everyone has a good night
thanks for the help
foreign